According to the insurer Hiscox, between 2019
and 2020, the share of companies affected by
cyber security events fell. At the same time, though,
losses from successful attacks are skyrocketing.
Garden-variety attacks are on the decline — but highly
sophisticated ones are becoming a major concern,
both for companies and all levels ofgovernment.
The more targeted attacks are sometimes
used for disruption, sometimes for espionage, and
features people with the skills of Russia's APT29
and APT28 groups. Russia's NotPetya attack
crippled Ukrainian infrastructure and a string
of global corporations. The Solarwinds hack, which
seems to have been a Russian espionage operation,
reached large parts of the US government, as
well as private companies. But state-sponsored
attacks may be the easier problem. Sometimes
the technology leaks to criminals who might
recklessly do even more damage than belligerent
states. The urgent question becomes: Can nations
agree to limit the proliferation of cyber weapons,
much like they have done with nuclear weapons?
How concerned are you about cyberattacks?
Let us know in our poll.
Also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe
for more research and videos from AEI.